دعى الرئيس الصيني شيجن بيج الى تعزيز
قدرات الجيش بلاده والاستعداد للقتال وقال
خلال تفقده مركز قياده العمليات المشتركه
باللجنه العسكريه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي
ان على الجيش ان يكرش طاقته من اجل تحقيق
هذا الهدف والوفاء بفعاليه بمهامه في
العصر الجديد وفقه
من جانبها قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
انها رصد 18 طائره واربعه سفن في المنطقه
المحيطه بالجزيره واضافت الوزاره في
تغريده لها على تويتر
واستجاب سريعا لوقف هذه الانشطه المعاديه
هذا ونقلت صحيفه فاينه شوتايمز عن مصادر
مطلعه قولها ان تايوان تحاول بناء سلسله
امداد محليه للطائرات بدون طيار في غضون
عام والتي يمكن ان تستخدمها في اي حرب قد
تنشب مع الصين وقال مسؤول كبير في الرئاسه
تايوانيه للصحيفه من الجيش التايوانيه
فاشله في تقديم مفهوم واضح استخدام
الطائرات المسيره في القتال اضافه الصحيفه
ان الحرب في اوكرانيا ابرزت الحاجه
للاستعداد للصراع في مضيقتي والدوره
الحاسمه الذي يمكن ان تلعبه الطائره
المسيرره